what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by today we have
some crazy news about Agatha coven of
chaos it looks like we know what the
main plot of the show is going to be
about and it is going to be about Agatha
of course but it is also going to be
about the Scarlet Witch Wanda's kids but
the story is going to be delivered in a
very interesting way and ultimately this
will lead up to the Scarlet Witch solo
project but right now we haven't really
heard anything about the Scarlet Witch
making a cameo in the Agatha coven of
chaos series there have been some
Rumblings about it but nothing from any
major Insider so right now that remains
to be seen however we have heard
recently from a major Insider how Agatha
gets released from one to spell if you
recall at the end of Wanda Vision Wanda
basically trapped Agatha in a mental
prison spell turning her back into Agnes
the role that she pretend to play the
whole time so what now
just gonna lock me up somewhere no
not somewhere
here
I'll give you the role you chose
the nosy neighbor wait wait
oh yeah
so when they announced an Agatha
Covenant of chaos series people were
wondering well how exactly is Agatha
going to break free is she going to do
that herself is somebody going to help
her and as it turns out yes somebody is
going to help her the Scarlet Witch
herself but she's not going to do this
directly or intentionally and the way
that this happens might make some people
wonder a little bit however we do have a
theory on what could be happening here
but according to The Insider can we get
some toast Agatha Harkness gets freed
because of the ending of Multiverse of
Madness and they show a clip of Wanda
pulling wundergore Mountain on top of
herself and here's why this is really
interesting because we know that Wanda
didn't die and even Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios has teased
this himself he said if you look at the
end when the rocks are falling when the
mountain is coming down there's a little
red light and of course most of us think
that that's Wanda taking herself away
teleporting somewhere maybe somewhere in
our current Universe maybe in a
different universe or a different realm
regardless we know that she's not dead
we know that she is coming back she's
already said she would love to come back
she's already talked about it a little
bit but of course is trying to avoid
saying that she is definitely coming
back because obviously they're trying to
make it seem like she died however
insiders have told us a Scarlet Witch
solo project is coming she's also set
herself and interviews that for her to
come back the story would have to be
pretty good so there of course is that
possibility so she didn't die but
apparently what she did at the end and
perhaps the dark hold being destroyed
will release Agatha then from there
we'll start the Agatha coven of chaos
Series in which we have a new synopsis
for and it's very interesting and might
be how we end up seeing the Scarlet
Witch later on Agatha coven of chaos is
definitely setting up a reunion between
Wanda's kids and herself first a reunion
between the two kids themselves and then
the two of them with Wanda this is not
synopsis and plot details is coming from
Insider Daniel rpk from his patreon
account and this is what it says Agatha
Harkness awakens from the spell and she
awakens to a boy now some have said this
boy releases her from the spell but like
I mentioned Insider can we get some
toast says that Wanda's apparent death
is what releases her but it goes on to
say that the boy asks for her help and
act at the Harkness forms a coven with
the woman of Westview to enter the
witch's Road a place where wishes can
come true now you may have caught our
last video on the Scarlet Witch and how
her solo project might also be centered
around the Scarlet Witch witch's Road
story and if both Agatha coven of chaos
and the next Scarlet Witch solo project
are going to be based off of The Witch's
Road there's a lot of connectivity going
on here which of course is what Marvel
does we'll talk about more in that
connectivity in just a second but to
finish the new plot synopsis it says the
witch's road is a place where wishes can
come true this is where the boy can get
what he wants and so can Agatha but to
get your wish you must pass a series of
dangerous tests now let's stop it right
there before we talk about the rest and
talk about the villains because we
apparently know what this boy wants this
boy is apparently Wanda's son Billy now
so far we haven't heard anything about
how Wanda's son Billy comes back we do
know that Wanda has seen versions of her
children Billy and Tommy in other
universes but in the current main MCU
Universe She simply created them so we
don't know how they're back perhaps
something she did with the dark hold off
screen that we don't know about perhaps
she did this in a way that she doesn't
know about but as far as what the boy
wants from The Witch's Road what we know
him to want is his brother Tommy so
however he gets back whatever means that
happens by he still knows that he has a
brother and he's trying to find that
brother now ultimately I believe that
the two of them are going to reunite and
then search for the next thing their
mother what would be the next step well
I found my brother now it's time to find
our parents well we don't really have a
dad because Mom created us by herself so
let's search for Mom and I think that's
gonna play a big part in the story of
the Scarlet Witch solo project but as
far as what Agatha wants we don't really
know at this point in time but we can
assume that she wants power she was
already a very powerful witch but then
she got defeated by the Scarlet Witch so
she probably has a lot of bad feelings
about that and probably wants to be an
even stronger witch however what we've
heard from The Insider can we get some
toast is that by the end of the show
since she's going to be helping Billy
she'll eventually go on to care for him
she's going to connect with him the
entire time and come to be sort of a
mentor to him and this is great because
this sets up a story for the Scarlet
Witch as well because in the comics
Agatha is the mentor to the Scarlet
Witch herself and in the comics when
Wanda loses her kids like she did in one
division Agatha actually erases the
memory of her children from Wanda's
brain now it doesn't end up working out
too well for Agatha because once the
Scarlet Witch actually remembers this
she ends up killing Agatha however
Agatha comes back as a ghost and
continues to Mentor Wanda and this leads
us to The Witch's Road Story the entire
storyline of the witch's Road Agatha as
a ghost is right there with Wanda and
it's curious because in the witch's Road
in this other realm Wanda runs into her
mother the original Scarlet Witch this
is something we could see happen to
Billy and Tommy in the witch's road if
it grants them what they desire they
could find each other and then their
mother in fact that could be how the
series ends the two of them get reunited
and they find their mother and that goes
into the Scarlet Witch story but like I
said there are going to be villains of
course it's a show it's a Marvel project
you have to have a villain and that
villain is apparently going to be
multiple people it's apparently going to
be the Salem seven the plot synopsis
continues to say to get your wish you
must pass a series of dangerous tests a
group of powerful witches known as the
Salem seven come to Westview to seek
revenge against Agatha follow her coven
into the witch's road now what's
interesting about this is that the Salem
7 in the comics each member had the same
father and that father was actually the
son of Agatha Harkness Nicholas scratch
so Agatha is actually the grandmother of
the Salem seven now in the comics they
all live in New Salem and they're
actually influenced by Agatha's son to
go against her and over the course of
several years the Salem 7 managed to
strip Agatha the heartness of her powers
and they actually win they eventually
catch her and burn her at the stake now
as far as what they'll do in the MCU
it's definitely going to be a little bit
different this plot synopsis says
they're going to seek revenge so
Agatha's been around for hundreds of
years perhaps even more so clearly this
is something that happened in the past
with their old coven and they're coming
to seek revenge so it's definitely
shaping up to be a pretty interesting
show so far one that I'm definitely
excited to see now as far as the release
date is concerned Marvel has pushed it
back but we do kind of have a window
based off of other Disney plus series
that are going to be releasing we know
Echo is coming out November 29th Loki
season 2 October 6th and we know that
the Daredevil Born Again Premiere is
summer 2024 so we are looking at a mid
to late spring of 2024 release date for
Agatha coven of chaos so go ahead and
let us know what you think about this
plot synopsis in the comments down below
are you excited for this series or not
leave us all your thoughts and don't
forget to subscribe and leave a comment
so you can enter our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month also we are on patreon now we have
a full functioning website as well and
have a Discord server we'll link all of
those in the Ping comment down below and
of course don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf wolf
baby